hey youtubers is charlie hopefully you
guys have all had a chance to rewatch
the Doctor Who premiere a couple times
in my review video asked you all to
submit questions so let's try and answer
some of the big ones mostly they were
about Missy as well as some of the big
changes there are a few important things
i'll mention after the questions but
let's talk about the episode first
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet all which is a
sec okay ready here we go question
number one amazed satsuma asks could
miss Eby mercy hartigan from the next
doctor special so there were so many
Missy theories that I just like combined
everything into this one question so
it's gonna be a little bit longer than
the other answers there are a few things
that we know about the finale this year
involves Missy and the Cybermen and
heaven the title the final episode is
death in heaven there were a lot of
suggestions you guys had in the comments
so mercy was one of them along with
Susan Foreman the doctors granddaughter
romana the Rani Tasha LEM a female
master or mistress I guess you'd call
her because she's a woman and another
personification of the TARDIS like from
the doctor's wife episode some of you
guys actually won't really detailed
explanations for you know why you
thought each of the theories was correct
but my favorites are Susan Foreman and a
female master another commenter Zachary
had a really good explanation for the
Susan theory first the doctor left her
in the far future and promised he'd come
back but then he never did remember how
I said the doctor leaving people behind
was a recurring theme in deep breath
along with the girl who waited you know
which is kind of what Missy's garden
looked like it's totally possible that
missy is a future version of susan that
explanation requires some rules get bent
on that resort planet that Amy Pond got
stuck on the disease there killed people
with two hearts so Susan would
technically died if paradise was that
same planet but it's also possible that
they just reused the set and it's just a
coincidence that it looks like the
garden from Amy's episode so we also
have to remember that missy is the
gatekeeper of the nethersphere so
wherever this is wherever she is it's
the nethersphere I think that's in the
pocket universe if you remember in the
trailer we saw the doctor entering a
pocket universe so at some point this
season we're gonna travel there so then
we have to look at Moffett's quote about
the finale his synopsis read you
betrayed me you betrayed my trust our
friendship and everything I've ever
stood for you let me down so really
anybody could be saying that to any
else like someone could be singing to
the doctor or the doctor could be saying
it to someone else it could be Susan
saying that to the doctor because he
never came back to get her so then the
next best theory going down the list is
the Ronnie I believe at some point she
got stuck in a pocket universe but
someone feel free to correct me she did
have a lot of stories involving
dinosaurs and we saw that giant one in
London the reason why I don't think that
it's her is because supposedly in the
novel she got her head chopped off like
she is dead so it depends on whether or
not you think the novels are cannon plus
i don't think the Ronnie ever had a
sexualized obsession with the doctor
like Missy seems to have so then were on
to the female master and Missy certainly
is a play on mistress this could be a
Moffat lies situation because supposedly
he said that the master is dead and gone
and a lot of you guys actually wrote
that in the comments you know Moffat
lies Moffat could just be saying that
the master is gone because he's turned
into the mistress so he could just be
using a play on words then there's Tasha
LEM she could have found a way to change
herself after being assimilated by the
Daleks after the Christmas special she
and the doctor did have a sexual
relationship at some point but the vibe
I got from Missy was so sinister that I
don't think that it was Tasha like her
relationship with the doctor wasn't ever
that toxic or at least they didn't seem
that way so then there's a theory about
Missy being a form of the TARDIS those
all stem from her use of the word sexy
like Missy could be some of the essence
of the TARDIS in female form like from
the doctor's wife she also refers to the
doctor's new accent and says I'll keep
it and if you remember during the
doctor's wife the TARDIS tells the
doctor I stole you you didn't steal me
so it implies like she has some sort of
ownership over the doctor like the
TARDIS owns the doctor on top of all
that if you look at the brooches both
Clara and Missy are wearing Clara's look
like the untempered schism / least I
thought it did and Missy's reminded me
of the lady in white so I guess you
could add the lady to the list of
possibilities although she seemed more
like the doctor's mother during end of
time not his girlfriend so I'll say the
best three theories right now art Susan
Foreman TARDIS essence and female master
but question number two likum films asks
did you notice when he told the robot
that you have changed your part so many
times that there was no trace of you
left was that a reference to himself
he's changed so many times that there's
no trace of the original doctor left so
that is a good question yes he was
totally talking to himself as much as he
was talking to the robot
moffat said a long time ago that the
doctor would regenerate passes limit but
there would be consequences now that
we're past the Christmas special we know
the Time Lords gave him a new cycle
which actually kind of reminds me of
deadly assassin when the master tried to
steal a new cycle of her generations but
I think they're still our original
aspects of the doctor inside of him even
though he's regenerated so many times I
think he just has trouble remembering
things like his mind palace has grown so
large it just takes him a little while
to find where things are the whole
exchange seemed like they were seeding a
big plot for series 8 as if the doctor
remembering his face and correcting
mistakes of the past are going to be big
recurring themes but on to question
number 3 James Swift asks do you think
that fires of Pompeii Capaldi is the
doctor in human form using the pocket
watch good pocket watch question but no
I don't think so i think some of his
familiar face talk was acknowledging the
meta thing that happened for Capaldi
previously starred in the series but i
don't think that fires of Pompeii
character will go further than that I
don't think it's like a major big thing
I think someone else in the comments
actually pointed out the Colin Baker
actually was a guest star on Doctor Who
before he became the doctor so doctor
who has done that before where they have
like a guest actor become the doctor at
some point Coghlan JV actually pointed
out the that the doctor supposedly
gave the watch to is actually Elisabeth
Sladen real-life husband so it's just a
nice easter egg on to question number
four nighy F asks hey Charlie does the
doctor get to choose what he looks like
whenever he regenerates so yes the
doctor can influence for generations
under certain conditions the master is
the only time lord that has complete
control over his appearance or that said
that he has complete control regardless
of circumstance The Sisterhood of the
car and have an elixir that can control
regenerations during the night of the
doctor before the 50th anniversary Paul
McGann regenerates into John Hurt's
specifically choosing to become more of
a warrior so there are devices that they
can use to influence what they look like
and what their personalities are going
to be it's also something that's tied to
relative scale like a highly skilled
Time Lord can influence their own
regeneration but there's always a
measure of chance I think in the novel's
they talk about the possibility of
regenerations ending in disfigurement if
you try to influence them too much but
as the series has gone on producers
avoided layers of complexity to the
science of regeneration so presumably
muffets going to explain what some of
the consequences of going beyond 12 are
there's also this really old explanation
that wrasslin
impose the rule of 12 for a very
specific reason I couldn't find any you
know really good details other than it
wasn't punitive like he wasn't punishing
the Time Lords by imposing the rule on
to question number five Shelley summers
asks what is the big deal with the
doctor giving the man his watch it's
only that the doctor can store his Time
Lord essence inside the watch like it's
a Gallifreyan watch and when I say his
essence I mean all of his memories and
his regenerations they are using the
pocket watch titles now so I don't know
if that's going to tie in with the
doctors actual story this series or if
it's just a coincidence not everything
that Moffat does is foreshadowing
originally whenever he wrote river song
into Doctor Who he didn't know that he
used her as Amy and Rory's daughter in a
future series whenever he took over but
the watch itself is just a really
infamous piece of Time Lord technology
but on to question number six chefs aunt
asks what about the doctors ring that we
got a good look at after the phone call
so thank you for mentioning this I
totally forgot to put in my review the
ring is the thing that they're going to
write into the story like it's going to
be part of the story this series in real
life Capaldi where's the ring to honor
his wife she's basically supported him
when his career went terribly as a way
to work with that Moffat had a proper in
mate to fit over that wedding band the
doctor has worn rings in the past the
first doctor wore a blue signet ring
they had some special abilities the
Seventh Doctor ended up finding it later
and then started wearing it again
supposedly the ring also belonged to the
other at one point the other was one of
the founders of the Time Lords society
along with rassilon and Omega if you
remember when they descended into the
ship in Clara got caught the robot
leader asked Clara where is the other he
never said the doctor's name he just
said where is the other so it could be
an easter egg for that famous other the
one that started the Time Lords society
supposedly he tried to escape Gallifrey
whenever Rassilon started to consolidate
his power he did so by jumping into the
looms the devices that the Time Lords
used to procreate the looms just
reconstitute genetic material to create
new children supposedly the novel's go
on to say that the looms reconstituted
the others genetic material into the
first doctor so whenever he reemerged
from the looms he was the first doctor
that doesn't mean that the doctor is
secretly the other is just the writers
winking at us
there were all kinds of really obscure
references in the episode like they
included a joke about the Scottish
referendum but on to question number 7
palahniuk asks what do you think the
writing in chalk all over the bedroom
floor was all about I think that's going
to be like Capaldi's cracks in the
universe I think that he's going to find
Gallifrey at some point this series it's
currently in a pocket universe and the
equations will have something to do with
getting there I also think that they're
going to tie in with the Missy plot in
the nethersphere I also think the
nethersphere is inside the pocket
universe too i think it's going to be
involved with finding Gallifrey question
number eight louis asks now that Capaldi
is an older doctor will we start to see
slightly older companions or will we
start to see older enemies such as the
Zygons return well they did say
revisiting old faces and there are a lot
of confirm you know returning enemies
the synopsis for the finale also says
that old enemies returned as to what
faces are returning you know I have no
idea but you can reference my favorite
Missy theories we've also seen the
Cybermen pictures and the Daleks are
back like the doctor said in the episode
I've seen all this before my hope is
that they use some of these familiar
things in new and interesting ways but
that's completely up to everyone that
watches it as for older companions I
mean if you consider people older than
Clara to be older than yes because I
think Danny pink is gonna become a
companion and he seems like he's a
little bit older than Clara but thank
you so much for submitting questions
guys is going to be a lot of fun talking
Doctor Who with you guys this series so
like I said my q and A's will always
post like the day after I do the reviews
just to give people time to watch the
episode and congratulations to the
winners of this week's giveaway smalley
mix mall and Rosie how you guys both
went amazon gift cards normally it's
just going to be one weekly winner but
since it's the premier and I'm so happy
doctor who's back I just decided to
double it but I'll mentioned you guys on
your channels for details i also just
wanted to say thank you to all you guys
for being so nice in the comments i knew
that there would be a lot of strong
opinions just based on all the changes
they made to the series since Matt Smith
left but all you guys did a really good
job of voicing your descent or dislike
in a really nice way there was a really
awesome shift that I posted during the
episode that sells up a lot of feelings
that I'm sure a lot of people had so I'm
actually working on a game of Thrones
video for tomorrow but my next Doctor
Who video will post Saturday morning
before episode 2 airs then I'll post my
review after and then obviously the day
after
at the QA but right now if you haven't
seen it yet I did that video just
explaining put mop and said about each
of the episodes you can click here to
watch it it's episodes one through
twelve and you can click here for my
episode 1 review thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow high
fives
you